oh man this is why people buy macbooks
this is gonna be interesting we have
apple's brand new m2 macbook pro and
dell's redesigned xps 13 plus not only
are we gonna compare the design
differences the displays the speakers
and webcams but also thermals and fan
noise cpu and graphics performance and
real-world productivity tasks to see
which one of these is the better laptop
starting off with design this thing
is a beauty this is what a 2022 laptop
should look like look at those slim
bezels and this screen is actually
slightly larger than the macbooks both
16 by 10. look at that keyboard we have
this bottom here that is completely
flush it does have a track pad i mean
this looks like a nice modern machine
compared to apple's design which is
straight out of 2016. the xps is smaller
i mean look at that it is hilariously
small it is also lighter and it's
actually ever so slightly thinner even
though it looks thicker because it has a
flat top instead of curved at the edges
on the left side the macbook has two
thunderbolt 3 ports whereas the dell has
one thunderbolt 4 and on the right side
the dell gives you one more thunderbolt
4 whereas the macbook has a headphone
jack so yes
this dell does not come with a headphone
jack that is crazy now they do toss an
adapter in the box but i do think that
is just crazy not to have one you guys
let me know your thoughts down below the
macbook has touch id to log in whereas
the xps has windows hello so it sees my
face and just logs me in automatically
now if you don't want to use that which
i don't know why you wouldn't there is
actually a fingerprint scanner built
into the power button as well as far as
the keyboards the macbook has a really
good one this dell as you can see spans
the whole width of the laptop without
any gaps between now it surprisingly
feels pretty dang good very close to the
mac it has some good travel and it has
some good feedback so i'm quite
surprised by it now right below of
course with the macbook we have this
trackpad it is amazing it has that force
touch and the dell you don't see it at
all it is hidden but it is not a diving
board keyboard it also uses magnets it
feels fantastic it does take a little
bit of getting used to the right spot
but i really like it now above that
people have been saying that dell copied
apple with their touch bar now these are
just capacitive keys i mean it looks
really clean it does work there's no
really feedback or anything like that so
i don't think it's as nice as the touch
bar even though we don't love the touch
bar this thing has an actual screen it
has a chip that does all the processing
it's customizable so technically this
touch bar is better before we check out
this ola display let's go ahead and
compare the speakers and the webcams
dell made a big deal about this having a
new quad speaker system so let's see how
good it sounds
[Music]
all right wow the xps definitely gets
louder it has more clarity the highs
really stand out i would say it's the
better speaker system now there's only
one thing that is bugging me and that's
the fact that the volume changes
based on how much bass is in your song
and i checked the settings the weird uh
upscaling stuff and the facts it's
turned off so take a listen right here
that's not too loud right and then take
a listen right here
the volume is getting louder
where there's no bass a lot louder
and then let's go back
so
i don't know it's just really really
weird i would rather have it be set to
one volume instead of trying to adjust
it i remember the sauna speakers used to
do that it was terrible now as far as
webcams and microphones this is apple's
720p webcam in their macbook pro with
their beamforming microphones and this
is dell's 720p webcam and their
microphones go ahead and let me know
down below which one looks better and
which one sounds better and now let's
compare the displays and we have a ton
of differences first off they are both
16 by 10. the dell is 13.4 inches
compared to 13.3 so slightly larger and
as far as the resolution it has almost
double the pixels we have the oled model
here it is also a touch screen and it
does look quite nice now can i tell the
difference between apple's retina and
then this higher resolution one no not
really eve at least from this distance i
can't see the pixels now we also have
the issue of windows scaling it's not as
good as mac os and because of that some
of the techs can look fuzzier at times
now as far as brightness let me go ahead
and max out both of these both of these
are rated at 500 nits but the dell does
look brighter not only that but because
it's oled it has better off access
viewing angles whereas the macbook it
loses brightness and contrast and as far
as reflectivity believe it or not but
the dell actually has better coatings
now than the macbook has and now let's
go ahead and play some video and see
which one looks better first thing i
noticed is just how much more saturated
the oled screen and the xps is i think
it's a little bit too much but of course
that can be easily tweaked in the
settings the highlights in this hdr
video definitely pop more on the dell
even though both have the same
brightness ratings and the deep contrast
is also better because it is an oled
panel i'm playing both of these back in
4k and i do see a little bit more detail
on the dell which has a lot more pixels
to make use of now when we shut the
lights off we really see a huge
difference look at that contrast the lcd
panel on the macbook looks great
compared to pure black with the oled on
the dell and playing back this hdr
footage it looks way better than on the
macbook i mean the difference is
dramatic now i can't believe i'm saying
this but dell
finally defeated apple with their
displays for watching videos it's great
the speakers now are a lot louder and
sound better as well and if you're a
content creator it can actually be very
color accurate as well but you do have
to know that with oled you wanna
calibrate the screen at one brightness
and leave it there there's really only
two downsides one the price it's more
expensive and two it really hits the
battery life and we'll talk about that
in just a bit and now let's get into
performance starting out with the ssds
now both of these do have 512 gigabytes
of storage and as you can see
the dell absolutely smoked the macbook
the dell's write speed is about 45
faster and as far as read it is pretty
much twice as fast now if you've been
following along with the macbook m2
launch you know that the base model is
significantly slower than this 512 and
then if you jump to a one terabyte or
two the performance stays the same
whereas the dell it will actually get
even faster because this is a pci
express 4 ssd so as far as our storage
the macbook gets killed and now let's
compare the m2 chip to intel's alder
lake 1260p
now yes this is not the 1280p model that
one is not out for another month so we
would love to test it but as far as
price points and ram and ssds this
system is laid out the same but the dell
costs 150
dollars more so this is a fair test and
the 1280p competes more with the 14 inch
let us know which one you'd rather have
us compare that 1280p to when that comes
out now this 12th gen chip has 12 cores
four of which are performance cores that
reach up to
4.9 gigahertz i believe whereas the m2
hits 3.49 at the max all right we have a
result and
i actually was not expecting this we
have 1548 for single core compared to
1934
so the m2 is 25 faster and as far as
multi-core it is 10 faster than the
1260p and yes the dell is set to best
performance and it is plugged in and of
course our macbook has been unplugged so
let's run the xps again unplugged set to
best performance mode all right we have
our results and this is unfortunate the
dell gets 44
slower even when it's set to best
performance unplugged compared to
plugged in and that makes it 60
slower than the m2 chip now the previous
xps when it was unplugged it performed
the same but the performance was always
right around 55 5600 meaning that if you
unplug it you're getting 11th gen speeds
and now let's go ahead and compare the
graphics i plugged the dell back in we
have intel iris xe graphics on the xps
and apple's new 10 core gpu with the m2
now one thing i've noticed so far is
that the dell spins up its fans all the
time even when downloading chrome when
the mac has stayed completely silent and
so far cool running these simple tasks
and it looks like the macbook is 67 and
a half percent faster in terms of
graphics now this is one area where the
high-end 1280p the more expensive chip
isn't much faster than this one and now
we're gonna run gfx bench which is
optimized both for metal and for vulkan
to test gaming performance all right we
have 48.5
compared to its side here but 19.0
that is
2.55 times faster such a massive
difference now some youtube channel said
you can game with the xps you just have
to turn your graphics settings down a
lot
and yes windows does have way more games
but this performance is not for gaming
and this is not a gaming machine now
we'll see how this translates to
productivity in just a sec now it is
definitely designed for web use so let's
go ahead and run speedometer 2.0 to see
how responsive alder lake is and we have
328 compared to 199 with the xbs now yes
this is a lot faster and it's faster
because that single core score and the
unified memory but 200 is still nice and
snappy now with that said if you do
switch over to safari i ran it here as
well we get 407 more than twice as fast
so i let both systems idle for about 10
minutes now and let's go ahead and get
an initial reading before we do our
stress test on the cpu looks like the
hottest point on the macbook is 28
degrees celsius
and then taking a look at the dell dang
all right 42
right there at the top i mean it's a
much hotter running machine and it also
looks like the graphics has to work
pretty hard to run this high resolution
display now let's go ahead and get
started with our 10 minute throttling
test and pretty much right away we're
hitting 99 100 degrees celsius on the
dell our macbook's at 70 and now the
dell slowed down just because it dropped
the wattage quite a bit as the fans are
spinning up now in a previous videos we
showed off how this macbook can hit even
up to 108 degrees celsius if you max out
the cpu and gpu or 10405 under more
easier use with just the cpu that's
because apple tries to keep these fans
off as long as possible as you guys see
here the fan is still completely shut
off the alder lake chip peaked at 64
watts whereas the m2 maxed out at 22.38
and we are still plugged in and set to
best performance
looks like our macbook is now hitting
100 degrees celsius at the hottest and
the fans are now kicking up and now that
it's been about four minutes of this
test they both settled in at right about
20 watts now unfortunately i don't have
any fan speeds for the dell but it's
running cool at about 75 degrees celsius
compared to about a hundred on the mac
with the mac running its fans not even
at half speed and staying quiet our test
is almost finished so let's look at the
temps we have 40 degrees for the macbook
and then for the dell we're looking at
about 43. so the dell actually cooled
down whereas dual fans are whereas the
macbook is starting to heat up there
right at the center where the m2 chip is
all right we are done and we have
8659 for the m2 chip macbook and 6335.
that is 36 better performance for the m2
chip instead of 10 that we saw in
geekbench now of course this is a
throttling test and the xps chose even
in best performance mode to slow itself
down to keep itself at around 75 degrees
celsius whereas apple doesn't care about
the chip getting hot now i also
previously tested just a single run with
the dell and we got 7507
so for short bursts the cpu difference
is only about 15
now i was going to test blender but i
think at this point it doesn't make
sense because the graphics performance
is low nobody's gonna buy the xps for
that so let's go ahead and test photo
editing i have adobe lightroom classic
open with 50 42 megapixel images
and as you guys can see
the macbook is definitely loading up
these raw images with effects added
quicker each time my switch has to read
the file which we know the ssd on the
xps is quick but then also has to apply
all of those effects as well and the mac
is much snappier now one reason maybe
the graphics performance i have the
settings opened up right here i have the
gpu enabled for both
but with iris graphics it says limited
graphics accelerations enabled not full
now we know that the actual performance
in our geekbench test for acceleration
of the graphics wasn't huge i mean it
was noticeable
but here maybe because of the graphics
memory and with the macbook you have
unified so you have access to more we
have a difference now i'm going to go
ahead and export these 50 images which
is not an extreme test when i did
wedding photography we would export 1500
sometimes 2 000 when we would shoot
weddings our settings are identical
let's hit export and our macbook is
definitely taking the lead alright guys
dang this is a big difference the xps
took two minutes and 54 seconds which is
not a bad time at all compared to last
generation generation before it is
faster
but our m2 took one minute and seven
seconds it is extremely fast when paired
with 16 gigs of ram and a 512 gig ssd
we know that the base model costs 1300
that takes two minutes flat now that
base machine also slowed down to four
minutes and 12 seconds when we had the
eight gigs of ram full and we were in
swap with 10 web browsing tasks open so
let's go ahead and open those same exact
10 web browsing tabs in google chrome on
both machines all right now let's jump
back into lightroom classic and let's
see how these machines compare when we
have a setup where we are using chrome
and we have different things open like
we typically do
and how the responsiveness is now as you
see we are using close to five gigs of
swap on the macbook even though it's a
16 gig model
and the windows laptop it just shows how
much is committed i don't have an easy
way to see swap all right our macbook is
done it took a minute and 14 seconds
exact time that we got last time we did
this test so just seven seconds longer
than with only lightroom open and the
xps took three minutes and four seconds
so about 10 seconds longer just showing
that we don't really get much slowdowns
with real world use whereas with the
base macbook and that slow ssd they put
in it it gets a ton slower so if you're
getting one of these macbooks make sure
to at least upgrade your ram or both now
i'm going to run this one more time
because i want to test out that
responsiveness we talked about in the
past that unified memory works way
better than regular and some other
youtubers are refuting us saying we're
wrong so let's just check out how these
systems are when you're you know having
something like rendering in the
background but you still want to do some
web browsing let's go ahead and switch
to our youtube video here
okay pretty good
let's check out our video game
the dell did have to reload that from
swap
the mac maybe had to as well but it was
much snappier let's check out this tab
here
once again um here we're still running a
background video on ign
here it looks like either it's paused or
it's switching through let's go to
electric
yep the mac
is super snappy with 16 gigs of ram
let's jump to our google drive
let's see if the whole thing is still
loaded up here it looks like it is and
while we're still running the export
let's do speedometer one more time which
is going to show us loading up new
websites google docs microsoft teams
office online all those kind of things
oh man this is why people buy macbooks
we have a lower number 273 than before
using chrome still with that render in
the background but on the dell we have
52.3 so the multitasking performance
went down
by 75
liter it's a quarter of what it used to
be
that is really crazy so that just shows
off even with 16 gigs on the windows
laptop and the ultra fast ssd
just the multi-tasking performance and
the performance of unified memory and
this whole apple silicon architecture
and how well it works together now if it
was safari it would be even better now
i'm going to go ahead and close all of
these tabs i'm going to close lightroom
and now i have davinci resolve 18 open
this is the studio version on both i
have a simple 4k h.265 project so let's
go ahead and see how it plays back both
of them are playing smooth both have
media engines there's an updated one for
alder lake uh so it's doing a great job
we have about 50 of a gpu being used so
we have extra room for more effects so
far i have two luts and film grain
applied here it looks like the xps is
doing pretty well it's only using a
little bit more gpu power and as far as
cpu we're getting about 22 usage
compared to about 11 so twice the cpu
needed to handle this footage and now
let's go ahead and export this five
minute project our macbook is absolutely
flying not being limited by the cpu or
the gpu here you guys see the usage it's
only limited by the encoders themselves
whereas with the xps we are limited not
by the cpu but by the graphics
performance and because of that we're
rendering at about 15 and a half frames
per second compared to 85 and a half
frames per second on the m2 macbook our
xps is finally finished and it took
seven minutes and 39 seconds for this
five minute project which is not too bad
it is faster than b4 but the m2 took
one minute and 26
seconds that is
absolutely
incredible
and it wasn't limited by the graphics or
the cpu now in final cut this took two
minutes and 20 seconds meaning the apple
has not yet updated final cut
to make use of their own hardware which
i just find insane where davinci resolve
they are on their game
one minute and 26 now in premiere pro
both will be slower the dell would be
quite a bit slower as well
but this is a fair test davinci resolve
is optimized for both
and wow
almost five times faster there
or maybe even more than five times
faster for the m2 now when people
comment and say well this m2 macbook pro
it's not really for pro users it's more
for people that use web applications or
some simple stuff it's just a marketing
term well this just shows you the
macbook is cheaper by about 150 bucks
and for real world usage both
multitasking photo editing video editing
unplugged performance it is just
incredible and with that same thing goes
for battery life now right now we are at
50 battery i cannot believe it we have
been shooting this video for i don't
know three and a half hours or so
running all of these performance
benchmarks pushing the machine to its
limits maxing out the screen brightness
and we're still at 50 percent whereas
the dell
it is at 77 percent now but most of the
time it was plugged in started out uh
pretty much with a full battery it
drained down to 50 something before we
even got into the performance test and
you know more than half of this video
has been plugged in and it's at 77. so
as far as the battery life the
difference is huge so with this kind of
a tough mixed workload the macbook won't
slow down and it will last you about
seven eight hours which is amazing
whereas the dell well it will slow down
and then it will last you probably about
three hours or so now dave lee showed
off with light usage which is how most
companies rate it just playing back a
video he gave this thing 9 hours and 40
minutes and the m2 macbook pro he gave
13 hours and 22 minutes now of course
that's probably with the dell in bounce
mode so it's even slower
and then with real world mixed use the
difference is pretty dramatic so just
like dave said apple can get away with
having an old machine because the user
experience is so good multitasking
performance not slowing down
with productivity it does great
especially if you get 16 gigs with 512
ssd and it's cheaper as well
now of course i do really like how the
dell looks really modern i love the
screen it's a great machine and if
you're going to do basic web tests email
some google docs things like that it is
going to do a great job and then you
might want to go for the 1080p display
not going to be as nice you're going to
miss out on the brightness and the
beautiful colors but the battery life
will get a lot better uh but overall i
mean the mac still is a better machine
if you're going to use it as a laptop in
this price range if you do some creative
tasks thing like things like that and
then if you don't well that is where the
m2 macbook macbook air will come in here
in just about a month so thank you guys
for watching click that circle above to
subscribe if you guys want to see more
videos like this one and if you
appreciate it check out one of those
great videos right over there that's
been max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]